est ce que quand vous faites l'amour est
ce que vous prenez des précautions
non pourquoi
parce que j'ai confiance et puis les
précautions une étoile dans vos
partenaires les deux et dieu général bon
alors en demeure un sujet qui touche les
préservatifs et vous mais après si c'est
de la fausse si c'est de l'intox
malgré les nombreuses campagnes
publicitaires les français continuent à
bouder les préservatifs ils refusent de
gâcher leur plaisir par un écran de
latex alors conscient que seul un
préservatif qui intensifierait le
plaisir pourraient répondre aux attentes
du public
les organismes de prévention lancent un
concours international de design
pourrait concilier sécurité et
sensations fortes
je crois que la plupart des utilisateurs
craignent que le préservatif soit un
obstacle aux plaisirs cet obstacle on le
comprend et un obstacle essentiellement
mécanique ce qui interrompt les
sensations
en réalité il serait temps d'en modifier
la structure la présentation et même de
réfléchir à une autre manière de se
préserver
50 % des couples dits à risque
n'utilisent pas le préservatif
aujourd'hui parce que cela leur enlève
du plaisir
c'est pourquoi nous avons créé ce
concours international ouvert ou
designers avec le concours des
associations de lutte contre le sida et
les industriels ce concours a pour but
de créer un nouveau préservatif qui
donnera envie d'être utilisés et
contrairement aux autres apportera du
plaisir plutôt que d'en retirer les
meilleurs prochain feront bientôt
l'objet d'une exposition ouverte à tous
patients en avant-première quelques-unes
des ébauches du designer philippe starck
quant à véronique marque courant et jean
michel cornu il nous propose un nouveau
concept basé sur une technologie d'avant
garde donc ce concept de préservatif
magnétique
il est destiné tout simplement à donner
plus de plaisir aux partenaires elle
semblait perdre magnétique qui permet en
fait de stimuler si vous voulez les
muqueuses en fait des deux partenaires
c'est-à-dire qu'on obtient quasiment une
absence une absence en fait de
préservatifs résultats de ce concours
international en décembre prochain à
paris quant aux nouveaux produits
il devrait arriver sur le marché dès
1993 reste une question demain après la
découverte d'un vaccin contre le sida
si ces nouveaux préservatifs donne trop
de plaisir les français pourront ils
alors s'en passer à votre avis est à
l'oreille
hatton avait moi je pense que c'est de
l'intox alors ça devient deux pas du
préservatif c'est bien de la personne
je n'avais plus de plaisir franchise
connaît vachement george michael
ils chantent michael voyons et toi je
pense que c'est toi aussi tu penses que
c'est bien le bergès pensent la même
chose si vous aviez une affaire terry sa
banderille et jacques vergès pour vous
défendre
moi je le prendrais ci prend pas cher
qui fonce à mais il peut ne rien y peut
rien ce qui fait sa grandeur passée
voilà et toi moi j'ai misé avocate star
c'est une star cette madonna bon
allons-y mon petit philippe bien thierry
à bakou franchement oui c'est dommage
parce que des capotes un peu plus et ce
serait vachement bien mais
moreira un gros cigare comme maître
vergès oui j'aurais un cigare comme m et
pour être sûr de ne rien rater de inler
dit tu es abonné vous y mettez un peu de
bleu